hello folks welcome to the 11th it's
january 11th usually i'd have this video
out
earlier in the month in the year but
i'll be honest
i wasn't even going to do this video
that was like half the movies are going
to be roll over from last year
also i was like what are the odds the
movies i'm looking forward to
in this video actually do come out in
2021 who just say they're not gonna be
delayed
but like the great samuel l jackson nick
fury himself
said until which time the world ends we
will proceed
until which time the world ends will
will proceed
as though it intends to spin on or
something like that i'm really
misquoting him i know
point is it ain't over till it's over
that's an easier one so we'll go with
that and yeah i'm gonna be honest with
you there are
two movies from last year's anticipated
movies of 2020 video
that roll over into this one but it's as
simple as this
not having them on this list it just
felt wrong
so i'm going to have them on here i went
back and forth with my head like well
wait a minute
well do i want to is it redundant then i
realize the whole thing is just
hypothetical this is a hypothetical
video
it's as hypothetical as it gets it's a
list of movies that may or may not be
good
in a year in which they may or may not
even come out
so as the great lincoln park once said
in the end it doesn't even matter
it's supposed to be a fun list so let's
just have some fun i'm rolling with it
all right so no need for the great
countdown of
nine eight seven six whatever starting
at the list with the two rolling over
from last year because we'll just get
those out of the way first of which is a
quiet place too was looking forward to
it last year looking forward to it this
year
the first one's great the second one
really wanted to see
maybe that's why he's on the list
because it hurts a bit more because it
was the next
screening i was going to go to you know
it was the next movie i was supposed to
see
then screenings just went away we were
this close to greatness
it's like whether you miss it by an inch
or a mile you still miss it but missing
it
by an inch just hurts worse than if you
miss it by a mile
i almost got to see it it stings but a
year later
still really looking forward to a quiet
place too also dune
had to put it on because i was looking
forward to it last year and then
later on in the year of 2020 the trailer
came out when we all thought we were
gonna get it a couple months after that
point is i was looking forward to it
before we had a trailer then i saw the
trailer and hype level just went through
the roof
great cast great crew great tone it just
looks like the dune movie i've wanted to
see for quite some time which
i guess is dune chapter one technically
i guess they took the first book and
they're dividing it into two movies
kind of like it how it is it chapter one
but it's just it was called it when it
came out so it's essentially the same
thing as
it only without the mass murdering
bogger clown but you get it pointy is
still looking forward to dune it was one
of my top anticipated last year
now top anticipated this year all right
we're gonna get this one out of the way
sure this is my list mortal kombat don't
judge
it's a new mortal kombat movie i'm a
lifelong mortal kombat fan well i guess
not lifelong because i've been a lot
can't talk today i've been alive longer
than mortal kombat's been around but for
as long as mortal kombat
has been around i've just been a fan
this is actually the movie on this list
i'm actually expecting it to suck what
can i say i'm just i'm not expecting it
to be good or great but it's a new
mortal kombat movie i'm baffled that
there's no trailer for this movie comes
out in a couple months it's like no
trailer
it's just that's how you're gonna play
it weird i'm pretty sure we'd all love
to see a glimpse of this thing this
again probably not gonna be good oh
god anyhow flawless victory let's move
on mission impossible seven i'm actually
expecting this one to be good it's like
mission impossible's the american james
bond movies essentially but whereas bond
movies are kind of intermittent with
what's good what sucks like they're good
bond movies bad bond movies you know
whatever mission impossible has been on
an upward trend it's like this
weird case where the sixth movie in the
franchise was
arguably my favorite one of my favorites
it's my favorite movie the year came out
i just loved it
six in the franchise the best that never
happens
hey there's the comment section in which
people are telling me all the instances
where that has in fact happened
i know you now this goes but tom cruise
is still got it he's still a bona fide
action star like when i'm his
age i will feel lucky if i get my
tapioca pudding next to me
while i'm participating in bingo night
how does he do it and those mission
impossible movies are still great most
importantly they're still
fun there's always they're always a fun
time at the movies am i looking forward
to it more than mortal kombat
yeah i am all right next up halloween
kills because we live in an age now
where it's like we have
sequels reboots and remake wolves and
we've seen it all but halloween which
was now
like you know they wiped out all the
halloween sequels so this is the first
halloween sequel
titled halloween that's a sequel to
halloween so we got halloween and
halloween it was the rare case in which
that was actually a really sweet return
to form
i love that john carpenter came back on
board the musical score was a great
rendition of that theme again
john carpenter had his hand in that the
new halloween movie was solid looking
forward to the sequel i hope they don't
overdo it i hope they don't just
overplay to where i get bored with the
whole thing again but safari i like
where it's going so sticking with the
horror theme we have candyman
which is the sequel to candyman so
halloween halloween candyman candyman
right point is last october i revisited
candyman for the first time in a very
long time
and i was blown away it's one of those
movies i was like oh yeah i remember it
being good but then you watch it you're
like
no this is actually great so there is
that so with this new
candyman sequel i feel like they're
taking it seriously
they want to make a great candyman movie
and i hope they stay in line with what
i liked about the original candyman it
was a compelling
investigative urban legend story and
then you had those horror elements in it
just it all worked with the original
candyman
and high hopes for the sequel also side
note in terms of observation i
find it interesting that in the original
candy man they said candy man had an
affinity for art
and this guy in the new one he's an
artist
don't know what it means but it's
fascinating i'm very interested in it
next up the matrix 4
fingers crossed i hope it's good again
with the world of
sequels and reboots and remake wills i
mean it's the matrix
4. it looks like it's a sequel don't
know how
but there are people who are alive who
shouldn't be but maybe it's their
consciousness in the code of the matrix
as we all very well might be like the
first matrix is a masterpiece the matrix
sequels are flawed sequels
with cool stuff in it can't deny the
meryl vinjian is pretty [ __ ] awesome
like
i mean i like him anyway but yeah the
sequel's never lived up to the original
i don't imagine the fourth one's gonna
live up to the original either but worst
case scenario it completely
sucks in which case the first matrix is
still a sci-fi masterpiece what's the
over under what do you think is going to
suck worse or be
better mortal kombat or matrix four
matrix four is probably gonna be better
all right next up we have venom let
there be carnage because
90s spider-man fan which means venom fan
the two go hand-in-hand
often and that is the case with me i
mean the original venom movie i mean the
venom
eddie brock thing i thought that was
amazing it's like it's like the warcraft
movie kind of where it's like
half that movie is actually pretty great
and the other half
not so much like with warcraft it's like
oh yeah all the orcs are amazing
the humans so that's how venom was it
was like oh venom and eddie brock
dynamic that's actually pretty great and
then you know the generic super evil
organization with the generic bad guys
no but now hopefully that takes a back
seat and we have venom vs carnage
which i've wanted for quite some time
can't help but look forward to that
next up spider-man 3 with some form of
word play that has to do with
the word home because it will spider-man
homesick spider-man
many homes spider-man homie d clown
whatever they're gonna call it i mean
let's be real with the marvel spider-man
movies like
marvel's spider-man movies at their best
is not as good
as raymie's spider-man movies at their
best so it's like their solution was
like all right well let's just bring the
raimi spider-man stuff
into the spider-man world for marvel
that there you go i mean legitimately
it's like they were sitting around going
all right what spider-man do people like
well spider-man do they love
and they really love that spider-verse
animation
all right well let's just bring in
spider-man 2 elements because we're
going to do a live action spider versus
movies like they're taking elements of
beloved spider-man movies and
throwing them into this movie which
works but in the end i hope it's a
good movie i hope it's a good spider-man
movie i hope it's not just fan servation
throw a bunch of fan service and
hopefully that just keeps it afloat
hopefully
that's enough there's a time in my life
that would have been enough absolutely
but it's just i'm not there anymore i
would like a good spider-man movie
i am concerned with it feeling bogged
down because where we left off in the
last movie spider-man's essentially you
know he's wanted that's that's
that's a cliffhanger you would think the
next movie would pick up on that but
it's like are they
going with that element and the
spider-verse thing that could feel
crowded they could pull it off but it
has my curiosity
and it has my attention and that brings
us to the last one on the list last but
certainly not lazy pinocchio
dude have you heard about this guillermo
del toro is
co-directing which right there you're
like all right well guillermo del toro
the one who gave us that
is co-directing a movie involving
horrific
imagery and situations like that which
i'm not gonna like pinocchio's always
been terrifying if you just
watch the disney animation you look at
it you're like
this is not for kids this is actually
pretty terrifying when i heard guillermo
del toro and pinocchio i was like
match made in heaven also here you go
cherry on top gonna be stop motion
animation it's like stop motion
animation
is unsettling enter exhibit a the bumble
don't judge
don't you know it don't even laugh i'm
hoping at least
one of you is like oh yeah he creeped me
out as a kid too otherwise
what can i say i'm strange but if i'm
really objectively looking at it i'm
sure the stop-motion animation
with the bumble's half of what creeped
me out about him anyhow i
i'm down for some guarama del toro
co-directed pinocchio stop-motion horror
i'm not even saying it's gonna be horror
i'm sad it
might not be maybe it's like dude it's
kid-friendly calm down i'm just saying
man there are a lot of elements there
that
work together and it might just be the
pinocchio movie i've wanted to see
ever since i was a kid i was like hey
mom and dad this is pretty [ __ ] up
stuff thanks for showing me though and
that's my list those are the movies i'm
looking forward to
in 2021 hopefully they come out i feel
like
a lot of them will at this point because
i feel like studios are figuring out how
to
roll with this this this what will this
year bring how will it unfold i don't
know
i will say though it's it's not like
you know time's a construct right so
that splice between 2020 and 2021
doesn't
really exist it exists for us but it's
still just
the same path we were on like we're on
the same path now that we
generally were on at the end of december
like you know on the yearly basis anyway
this
there's no real hard splash like okay
shit's different now because
january 1st it makes for fun jokes about
surviving 2020
absolutely but in the end it's uh
2021 is probably gonna have a lot of the
that which made 2020 2020 but in the end
if you go back like 2016 was like the
cursed year of 2016. so they had that
you know oh me at the beginning of 2016
me at the end of 2016. like that was a
thing people threw up on twitter same
thing with 2017
18 19 and 20. i mean 2020 definitely
felt like a unique animal in which there
were
things in 2020 that i hadn't seen
in my life prior but still the fact that
it's been a running joke of
hating the end of the year for a few
years prior to 2020 it's
something i think about so as we go
forth through this year knowing it's
going to
have a lot of those 20 20 hardships
still going on let's just keep things in
perspective
as to what matters all right a lot of
that heavy stuff out of the way after
the
fun video of 10 anticipated movies but
your top 10 anticipated movies for 2021
what are they whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you